i've come to taipei taiwan to catch
three world-class fish but it's water
ways of taking a beating and unless i'm
smart with my fishing
i will too
are you kidding me
i'm mike iaconelli my friends and i grew
up fishing the mean streams and rivers
of philadelphia
[Applause]
[Music]
all it takes is a little skill and a
local let's go to show you where the
fish are biting
[Music]
excuse me for having such a taipei
personality
taipei taiwan
funky crowded and exotic
it's one of asia's great cities
and is home to 2.7 million people
and i have just one week to decode it
and catch my three bucket list fish
but first thing i need to catch is some
luck
and nobody knows more about luck than
the chinese
hi hey hi
hi mike
this is my first time at a fortune
teller
first time
i'm excited i want to ask you a little
bit about my chances of catching fish
this week oh my gosh
wow you can
that'd be awesome
that'd be great
yo you've been
fortune-telling finches are popular in
taiwan
they say they can peer into my future
and know what's in the cards
please bird help me
wow i've been red carted before but
never buy a bird
and my fishing fortune is
everybody knows that
i'm after three of the city's most
fascinating fish
there's so many cool fish in this part
of the world i'm like a kid in a candy
store i can't wait to get my hands on
them
first up is a traveler like me the
african catfish these fish are world
famous but i've never even seen one
african catfish can grow to five and a
half feet long and don't only live in
africa
they've been transported to many
countries as livestock for fish farms
lurking under these murky polluted
waters lies some true giant fish
i'm going to start right in the middle
on the key long river
the kilong flows out of the mountains
behind taipei and toward the sea
and this river is known for carrying
gold
but i'm on my own treasure hunt and this
guy is my kind of prospector
max
oh mike how are you finally you here
very nice it's great to meet you in
person
i found max on an online fishing forum
he knows a lot about taiwan fishing
and finding the right guy in the right
waterway is key to catching the right
fish
yeah it looks like low tide yes title
yeah so it goes up and down yeah but now
it's low tide and now it's perfect time
so we got a fish quick yeah okay african
catfish yes how big big one big one
okay
i'm ready let's go let's go
i'm following you
low tie can be a good time to fish
because the fish are compressed into a
smaller area
what time does the water start coming
back up
it's we have maybe three four hours
three hours yeah hoping to go out yeah
yeah they they start to leave
if we don't catch a catfish in the next
three hours the canals are gonna fill
and finding our fish will be much harder
okay it's that way up these steps
this river has a dark past
almost on this exact spot in 2015
trans-asia airways flight 235 lost power
and crashed
killing 43 people
max says fishing was never the same
again the native fish used to catch here
disappeared and the african catfish
moved in
we're racing against the tide so max has
a plan to double our chances okay i have
an idea uh maybe we can put two road
okay to that
down there
all right so plan is to put two rods out
with bait yes and then we'll come back
yes and we start
uh we start casting here lure okay that
sounds like a plan yep let's do it let's
do it okay
we're gonna cover more water by casting
some baited hooks deep into the channel
and leaving them to do their work while
we fish the rest of the channel with
lures
so we can put the dead bait in the mouth
of the river yeah
and just
just go cussing okay let's do it
our bait is super stinky mackerel it
will leave a long scent trail in the
water that the catfish can follow
oh that smell that smells good yeah very
fishy
catfish can hunt using their eyes their
nose by taste or by touch and in these
murky conditions a scent trail of
mackerel will be perfect for luring them
in
really cool scenario um
perfect spot to catch fish in general
but especially the african catfish if
you look at it
you've got a tributary that's coming out
this is a small stream
and it's meeting
the main river here
we're gonna throw it out there and leave
them
and hopefully catch a big cat that's
right at the mouth of this tributary
while we're waiting
we're gonna grab
we're gonna grab our artificial lures
we're gonna go back up and we're
actually gonna sight cast
for some big african catfish with our
eyes so i think that's a good plan
small river meets big river meets tidal
flow
there's something for everybody here the
fish will love it
you know we're gonna leave these baits
out but we're gonna turn the drags real
loose
so
if we're gone and that fish bites
that fish is gonna be able to take the
line
and we're gonna hear that noise of that
fish streaming away and we're gonna run
back and jack a big one
now i've got to be honest i thought max
was gonna be a chinese guy
but he looks more like a viking
so max yep where are you from originally
oh originally i'm from russia from
russia yeah from moscow what are you
doing here i think it's unbelievable for
you but i'm software and hardware
engineer software and hardware engineer
yeah five years ago i do smallest pc in
the world
wow yeah that's awesome so you're smart
i don't think so
you gotta be smart to outsmart these
african catfish
so this is a russian computer genius and
his trusty sidekick the american bass
fisherman versus the legendary african
catfish
and they've got super powers
some catfish can hunt in a pack
and they'll even hunt out of water
in france these catfish have learned to
take pigeons from dry land
when pigeons come down for a drink the
catfish pounce
but that doesn't make them team players
african catfish are like electric eels
and can use their skin to electrically
shock other catfish that get too close
yes yeah all right after after let's go
let's go let's go
yes yes yes yes
is that an african catfish yes yes it's
kid oh max i really want to catch one of
these things
max knows his stuff this water is
crawling with cats african catfish are
famous for being able to live in the
worst water conditions
even urban sewage systems
they seem to be thriving in this water
and there's more water every minute the
tide has turned and as the river gets
deeper my chances of success get smaller
[Music]
you know i've caught tons of catfish in
the united states uh-huh but it's not
africa never caught an african catfish
you have a good chance oh oh but i think
one of the reels going off all right
let's go let's go
i can hear the real screaming that means
we might have a monster on the line
where's the land in there
blending it
i feel like i got a dinosaur on here
a lot of big surges trying to
it's trying to get me back out to that
current in that deep water there are
also rocks just below the catfish
if it dives it could tangle or snap my
line
the water's coming up fast and this
might be my only chance ah mike let's go
there no no i got it
day one in taipei taiwan
what are the reels going on i'm a
stranger in a strange land trying to
catch a fish i've never caught before an
enormous african catfish and it's about
to get away
[Applause]
ah mike let's go there no no i got it i
got it try the pool down yes try this
my fishing buddy max wants me to move
down the river to a deeper pool where i
can tire this fish out
but if i take the pressure off it'll
throw the hook right out
[Applause]
come on come on
oh my god
look at that thing oh god that was cool
this is unbelievable
we're up there casting and we heard the
reels
came down and caught this thing i told
you the best time now low tide yes oh
look at the size of this
look at that thing
unbelievable fishing
you know these things are amazing
they've got
a really primitive air bladder right
above their gill
that gulps air
and they can live a super long time out
of water
this thing can gulp air
and live four or five days out of water
because they breathe air they can live
in water that's uninhabitable to most
other fish
if their home is drying up they can even
bury themselves in the mud until the
rains return
god i've caught more fish than i can
remember
gonna let this thing go but this african
catfish is a first for me it's one less
fish on my taiwan bucket list
wow
yes let's go
wow sweating
i haven't run that fast since grade
school
[Music]
it's been a long day and the adrenaline
is fading but it's time to celebrate my
first
catch and here in taipei there are bars
just for fishermen
man i love this city
can i rent a ride oh okay yeah and bait
armed with my fishing rod and fresh
chicken liver for bait okay
i'm ready to stake my claim by the pool
[Music]
you've heard of byo restaurants well
this place is cyo catch your own shrimp
the idea is you keep fishing for shrimp
until you have enough for a meal
and then you get them cooked up and eat
them right here at the pool
[Music]
but there's more than just the scent of
grilled shrimp in the air there's also
the smell of competition
i'm nervous i feel like i'm in a big
tournament here
i feel a little intimidated right now
like everybody's watching and waiting
for the new guy to screw up
now don't go messing with all night now
i think this guy's playing me moving my
rod to a place where the shrimp don't go
against the wall
oh
so the first rule of shrimping that i
just realized is you don't set the hook
hard
because then you just come back out with
a leg
and the rest of the shirt
is not
gentle
don't worry like many crustaceans shrimp
can regrow a lost leg
what the hell
dude that's embarrassing
getting showed up by a little girl
this is horrible
a double
oh i'm getting mad now
you know what's frustrating is
watching everyone around me catch these
shrimp
i'm a decent angler i've won my fair
share of bass tournaments in my life but
i can't catch a damn shrimp this is
crazy
i think this guy's taking pity on me now
and i think he's showing me that letting
out just enough line to hit bottom is
the trick to shrimp
fishing got one
thank you
finally one hour and 13 minutes in
i hooked my first shrimp
and there it goes
beautiful beautiful creature
you know a lot of people come here to
catch these and eat them
you can catch them bring them back on
the grill cook them and literally eat
what you catch
but i'm a sport fisherman i believe in
catch and release
thank you shrimp
it's been good
my first day here has been catfish crazy
and totally shrimptastic
but tomorrow the challenges are
because i have to find my next fish
in the middle of a major waterway
day two in taipei it's warm with a
chance of rain which is pretty much the
weather report for every day of the year
i'm up early and dressed for success to
make my next catch all right i know what
you're thinking
what's up with the super skin tight
pants
listen there's a reason for this i had
my wife becky pack these pants
because they're lucky pants 15 years ago
i wore these same pants and won a big
tournament so i've got to wear these
pants today fat roll and all
the steaks are just as high today
because i'm trying to catch a fish that
i've never caught before
today my catch is a japanese sea bass
i've caught millions of largemouth bass
and fresh water in the states
but i've never caught a sea bass here in
taiwan
very excited come on let's go
for years pollution has made taiwan's
dan shui river almost uninhabitable to
fish
but a lot of effort has gone into
cleaning up this waterway
i'm headed down to the docks to meet a
local fisherman who says the big bass
are back
how you doing
are you list
yeah i'm this mike guy canale yeah nice
to meet you i'm excited good to meet you
we're gonna catch big sea bass today i
traveled all the way from the united
states to taipei to catch one of these
things come on let's do it before we we
go fishing we need to craze oh okay look
yeah it's our religion sounds great okay
we come here okay let's do it
no fisherman ever turns his back on the
chance for some luck but the chinese
specialize in it shrines like this are
common
and in this case i really do need some
good fortune i'm dressed for it and now
i'm asking for it
please bless us with some sea bass today
we need every bit of luck we can get
and also i have on my very tight disco
pants
thank you
okay
ready fishing time yeah fishing high
come on let's go
we're in taipei yeah tell me a little
bit about this area where are we what's
what is this river what's the name of
this okay this one is dantri river
is in the
city center of taipei
the word dan shui means fresh water but
for the last few decades there's been
nothing fresh about it
last year it was listed as the 16th
dirtiest river on earth delivering 40
tons of trash into the pacific ocean
every day
i think the government and the general
people they don't they don't care about
it so right
i think if we can
get big fish maybe
public will
focus on this
list is hoping that if we can show big
fish are returning as the water quality
improves it'll keep everybody on point
in the united states that happens all
the time as people learn
there's beautiful fish in the river yeah
they care more about it
every fisherman should think about
conservation that's important yeah we're
not only the fishermen we are also
environment protectors that's right yeah
so there's more at stake than just
catching a big fish today
but where am i gonna find them
i'm looking around i don't see anything
that breaks the current except that yes
they've got to pass that bridge it's
like a barrier yes and they're going to
use those pilings of that bridge
to get out of the current not only to
rest but also to feed
[Music]
good fishing requires some detective
work and i'm sherlocking the fish right
now
they need some kind of current break
this current's so strong in this river
that they've got to get behind something
or next to something
even under the water there's other carat
breaks there's random pieces of concrete
that have fallen in i can feel trees
and all that stuff provides the current
break to get these fish
[Music]
there might only be one or two fish
under this bridge so it's a case for
being persistent patient and covering
every bit of water
so we are waiting for a big fish
that one big one yeah already
[Applause]
listen to me okay
i traveled all the way from the united
states to taipei to catch a sea bass no
this is smooth scene
i don't care
man that's not a big one that's a pretty
good one but look at the
look at the color
look at the dots on that thing
and if you look at it you can tell
this thing is built this thing is built
for these conditions
rapid current this current is ripping
and if you look at the way that fish is
built he's real long and lean to live in
that heavy current japanese sea bass are
given different names in japan according
to how big they are
first they are called coppa
then they grow to become sago
then fuco or honey
and a really big japanese sea bastard is
called suzuki
congratulations go first thank you i'm
very happy
bye bye bye fish thank you very much
here it goes
just like that baby
okay so the d'anchuay river has sea bass
and i've ticked off my second bucket
list fish
but i'm not done yet because the list
believes there are bigger bass here
still to be caught
we're actually getting closer to the
best window of the tide which is high
we've got about an hour and a half till
it'll fully peak out i think if we're
going to catch a big one it's going to
happen in this higher water
like their name suggests sea bass live
in the sea but they'll also come up the
river to feed and can be found around
structures like bridges
oh big one giant this is the one oh my
god oh get out of that pilot
this is the one
this is the one hold it in that net for
this one that yeah yeah net okay
this is the one this is the one please
stay on there god
[Music]
i'm fishing on taipei's danchuae river
and whatever i'm dragging up right now
is a lot bigger than my bass this
morning
big one giant this is the one
let's come to the back go in the back
okay
oh my god
this is the one yeah nice this is the
one please god
heal folk
here he comes here he goes
get it get him
[Music]
we did it
yeah we did it yes wow
yes
wow
look at that thing
massive beast
caught a lot of fish in my life i've
caught a lot of largemouth bass
with the chance
to come
across the world
to taipei
taiwan
taiwan
and catch a fish of a light
man oh thank you
thank you fish gods that i prayed to
earlier oh dude i'm so happy right now
like many kinds of fish sea bass are all
born as females
then around two years old a few of them
turn into males
why it's common in fish that live in
harems with one guy and many gals
but i prefer to think they're just
enjoying the best of both worlds this is
the best part of it right here
catch a world-class fish
and now we get to release it
there it goes give me five
yeah
not long ago fishing in the dan shui
just wasn't an
catching
option
three-foot long sea bass is proof that
the river is making a pretty exciting
comeback
i came here to catch an african catfish
and the cat's in the bag
i came here to catch the biggest sea
bass i could
and that job is done
i've got one more mission in taiwan but
it's going to be the hardest of all
the giant snakehead known locally as
tomin is a ferocious and famous fighter
you need a lot of luck to hook one and
you'll need twice as much luck to land
it
so i'm headed to one of the most
important buildings in all of taiwan
it's a place across town that's been
dishing out good luck to the local
chinese for almost 300 years
even getting there is gonna take some
luck check out this traffic
there are over 1.8 million registered
vehicles in taipei and almost a million
of them are scooters look at that
but you know how many people died on
these roads last year just 65.
chicago has the same size population and
they probably lose almost twice that
many
chinese luck indeed
when it comes to packing people in
taipei is amazing more than 25 000
people per square mile
and i love it you want to try it all
right you try
try it it's cast there and it set the
hook though
i want to fish right here though because
that's where i want to fish yeah i want
to catch that sea mass right there
here's a great example of some of the
species that can be found here
we've got squid
beautiful
we've got
sea bass
we've got
tilapia
mullet and of course red snapper
great look at what lives right here in
taipei
[Music]
this is what i've crossed the city to
see the beautiful longshen temple
[Music]
it was built in 1738 as a place for
chinese settlers to gather
and talk about luck
the temple has been destroyed over and
over again by earthquakes typhoons and
even a bomb but it's always been rebuilt
and restored
visitors can pray for love luck or
fortune for more than 100 different gods
and goddesses here
i've chosen taiwan's most popular folk
deity
matsu goddess of the sea and protector
of fishermen
hopefully she'll set me in the right
direction tomorrow when i go fishing for
the giant snakehead
i'm up with the early morning commuters
here in taipei and heading to meet an
expert who could put me onto my last
fish on my list
he's a big time guy for international
anglers
here we go we're on the metro
headed to meet peter
you know the mission today is to try to
catch a snakehead
giant snakehead can grow to 40 pounds
and nearly four and a half feet long
they're one of the fiercest fish that
you could ever catch in fresh water
uh are you mike i'm mike iaconelli yeah
mike welcome to thai bear thank you are
we fishing first giant snakehead today
right okay this is a secret okay giant
snake
hide in the center central city now
at home when it's really bright and
sunny yeah it's super tough to sight
fish is that gonna i mean i heard
everyone just think something that is
good no for jonathan had laid down
fights in sunny day every people just
want to get bigger to understand ahead
right so it's quite a habit so these
fish are going to be spooky not easy to
catch you're just like a sniper if you
sing let you just one shot a chance one
shot only i'm gonna have one cast to
catch this fish
geez they're smart they're easily
spooked i'll only get one shot and they
don't bite on sunny days
sorry everything sounds like a lot of
pressure peter
let's go
sounds like the fish got to matsu the
goddess of the sea before i did
peter's taking me to the jingle river
which runs from old taipei into the new
modern part of the city
it's part of a huge riverside park and
cycling path that runs through the city
and this clear water is more bad news
all right peter you ready we're gonna be
down there
we're gonna sneak up on them we're gonna
take our time okay okay all right let's
go
[Music]
i
[Applause]
[Music]
no it's okay it's okay keep going keep
going keep going
stay here
what
i'm putting my lure right on the money
but they're super spooky i can't tempt
one
say
nice size
i put
you
it's all four come get one to bite
this is the most frustrating thing in
the world
when you're sight fishing like this and
you can see these things
and they're so pressured they're so
spooky you can't get them to bite it's
killing me because
this is what i came to taipei to catch
it's a story of my life with snakeheads
they hate me
we're seeing so many snakeheads
and we can't get any to bite i i gotta
catch one of these things peter
first thing to do is get away from the
shallow water it's not helping anybody
this spillway looks promising
look at the birds
they're hanging out here because there's
fish to be caught he's stalking and the
rough water means the fish here won't be
so nervous
i can't see them and they can't see me
that one ah nine nine nine nine right
and sure enough there's a fish here who
wants to bite
i'm hoping it's a snakehead bite
i'm fishing in taipei's jing-mei river
and at last i might have a giant
snakehead on the line
but this is not a snake head this is a
tilapia there you go a fine fish but not
a bucket list fish beautiful fish very
common
but this is the national
treasure
right here
downtown taipei
man this isn't my giant snakehead
but i'm pretty excited to catch this
thing
look at the grays and the blues in that
fish
beautiful beautiful there are dozens of
different species of tilapia it's one of
the most eaten freshwater fish on the
planet they're everywhere
taiwan exports more than 100 million u.s
dollars worth of tilapia every year
it's funny a lot of times man when you
come fishing you
you want to catch one kind of fish
you know i had my heart set on snake
head today
it just didn't happen
sometimes switching gears
and just having something pull back
man that's just as important
you know to be able to say that i came
to downtown taipei
right in the heart of the city
and catch something have something pull
back
that's that's pretty cool man
it's getting late and still no snakehead
not today at least
but i've still got hope and even better
peter says he's got a friend who might
be able to help me out in the morning
[Music]
i hit the road early and i'm headed to a
place called lake zunguin more than
three hours to the southwest of taipei
the lake was created by damning the
zhongwen river and it's massive more
than 4 000 acres
peter has plugged me into a friend who
knows how to fish this lake
that might be my guy right there
he's a guy and a dinghy
it may be him
dwayne christie is a taiwan fishing
legend in 2012 he caught what was at the
time one of the heaviest snakeheads on
record whoo
dwayne hey mike welcome good to meet you
yeah man it's great to meet you how are
you i'm great i've come a long way from
taipei to get here and this is
mind-blowing the scenery here is
mind-blowing definitely worth the trip
and effort to get down here that's for
sure
i traveled literally from the united
states to come here for
one reason a giant snake head i gotta
get my hands on that monster no you i'm
gonna put you on a couple of spots where
you can definitely have a good chance of
getting it fishing's fishing we all know
that yeah but i'm pretty confident i
like the positive vibes let's do it yeah
man let's do it
with a lake this size if you had a
million cast you still couldn't fish it
all the trick is not to even try
you know what we're targeting are points
and cuts and if you look at this bank
it's a real good view of these rocky
points that jut out
snake had loved to hang on those points
to ambush their prey
this lake is so huge i may only come
across one or two giant snake head
my tactics and tackle choices have to be
right on the money no second chances
we're trying to trigger what's called a
reaction strike from these fish
the faster you move the bait the more
you kind of force that fish to bite it
this is what i came for this is giant
snakehead territory
monsters live in here waiting for that
first bite
one of the unique features of a giant
snake head
is it has air bladders it actually has a
set of air bladders positioned behind
its gills
the giant snakeheads air bladder is also
a big help to us
because sometimes they'll reveal
themselves with a telltale trail of
bubbles
and it looks like we've got company
no
yeah oh my god
the hell was that that's all stinking
i'll get that
right
that's all snakey dwayne has wrestled
the giant snakehead out of the shallows
so it's only got one place left to hide
and that's right under the boat there's
so much tension on the line now that if
the line just touches the rough part of
the boat it'll break clean off got to be
real careful here oh look at that was a
good fish hit
ass
it looks like a giant to me you see as
soon as he gets to the boat all he does
is dive under the boat
the fish is gone
and maybe so are our chances
that hurts man
[Music]
but at least i know there are giant
snakehead in this lake we just gotta
keep grinding now
[Music]
stop stop
stop
come on man
unbelievably one follows the lure right
to the boat
then misses it
i suck
i am the worst
take me back
it's my last day in taiwan
yesterday i left the city and traveled
south to a huge lake
but still couldn't land the elusive
giant snakehead
tina
come on man
with just one day left this could be the
end of the line
second day second chance got an early
start this morning perfect conditions
really calm this morning
water's a little cleaner
and this is going to be a really good
opportunity to catch one
man we had some chances yesterday and it
hurts
it hurts really bad to come so close and
not closing on it
today i want to get those chances and
close on it
let's do it bro
we're fishing a series of pockets if you
look at the banks here
these banks are really soft they're more
mud banks and
all of our bites over the last day and a
half
90 of them have come from these type of
banks so
this might be the place to catch a giant
snakehead
[Music]
the mud banks are exposed because right
now the water levels are low
but taiwan is hammered by rain receiving
more than eight feet of precipitation
every year
it took years of planning but when they
finally finished building this dam in
1973
they designed spillways in the dam so
that it didn't get destroyed by floods
let's just hope they didn't flush out my
giant snakehead
come on
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm shaking
[Music]
got him yes
sit sit sit make sure you sit you got
him it's a big one
it's a giant
it's a giant this is the one
come on god please
this is the one
place down here
oh god please
please help me when he gets to the boat
he's gonna try and go under so just
watch for there
let's get him
let's get him you ready you ready yep
get up get him no no no he's not ready
he's not ready he's not ready
this is where we missed one yesterday
right at the boat this is the danger
point right here
yeah
that thing's awesome buddy you all done
look at that thing it is a beast
this is what it's all about
yeah he wasn't going nowhere if fishing
don't get you excited
you got problems
both of us had so many missed
opportunities and to finally catch that
fish man this is this is a special fish
for me
this is my first giant snakehead
i'll never ever forget catching that
fish
much like a shark the giant snakehead
has pointy teeth with two cutting edges
on every tooth
which gives them the frightening ability
to slice their prey clean in half
man this is a fish of a lifetime
and it completes the trio for me
african catfish
japanese sea bass and last but not least
the giant snakehead
unbelievable
we'll let this thing go another guy's
gonna have a chance to catch it
thank you for helping me catch that
thing no it was only a pleasure only a
pleasure that's not only the fish of
this trip it's probably one of my one of
the fish in my lifetime i can tell you
that it was unbelievable fantastic i've
got a long trip back to taipei
i'm gonna hit the road but man thank you
once again
and the only thing i have to catch now
is my plane back home
[Music]
you